new oversight measures are now in effect
for Greek life organizations at Penn
State University they were implemented
in response to the death of Timothy
Piazza earlier this year prosecutors
alleged the sophomore was hazed into
drinking excessive amounts of alcohol at
a party he has his parents push Penn
State to make changes and they are here
this morning with their reaction in an
interview you'll see only on CBS but
first here's a look at the tragedy that
led to the new measures preliminary
hearings are underway for members of the
now-closed Beta Theta Pi frat house 18
of them are facing charges in connection
to the death of sophomore Timothy Piazza
Piazza died in February following an
initiation ceremony that involved heavy
drinking he fell down a flight of stairs
and hit his head repeatedly often in
view of his fraternity brothers no one
called for help
until the following morning during
hearings in July the prosecution
presented apparently incriminating text
messages sent from some of the frat
brothers I don't want to go to jail for
this wrote one member the boys
themselves knew what they did the text
admit it right after before he even
passes away they say it's because of a
hazing it's because of the drinking we
caused this we should have called 9-1-1
but lawyers for the 16 defendants who
appeared at the preliminary hearing
claimed the evidence doesn't warrant a
trial some argue the brothers didn't
force Piazza to drink and can't be held
responsible for knowing the difference
between intoxication and serious injury
two of the brothers waived their right
to a preliminary hearing
now with the fall semester underway Penn
State President Eric Barron is
implementing more than a dozen reforms
to Greek life at the school the
university will take responsibility for
oversight and discipline of fraternities
and sororities social restrictions
addressing alcohol use will remain in
place as well as a no tolerance policy
for hazing Timothy Piazza's parents Jim
and Evelyn Piazza are with us now along
with their attorney Tom Klein good
morning Maureen thank you for being here
thank you
we've got the school year starting up
again it's been six months since your
son's death how are you doing it's hard
especially having to bring our son back
to school this past weekend this is your
Penn State it's your older son yeah yeah
yes so we were normally we make a couple
day trip out of it we were in and out
the same day we just couldn't couldn't
stick around it was it was hard knowing
that we should have been bringing two
kids back yeah Jim we now know that Penn
Penn State has announced some of these
changes which you have been pushing for
your family has been pushing for are
they enough well you know I think
they're a good start we've been in
contact with President Barron for the
past six months about proposals that
they need to implement and many of the
proposals that they've put forth or our
suggestions but there's still more that
they need to do they really haven't
implemented a lot of them yet and at the
end of the day they need to implement
and more importantly enforce but we're
happy to see that they've taken
responsibility and said that their
oversight has been severely lacking for
Greek life and we're happy that they're
taking responsibility for disciplinary
actions but they have the same people
involved and those people were
ineffective so I'm concerned about that
one of the defense attorneys argued in a
hearing recently that nobody forced Tim
your son to drink instead expecting
young men to be able to distinguish
between extreme intoxication and a head
injury quote he says quote places an
impossible burden on them what do you
say to those who argue that listen this
was just a tragic accident no they said
right away somebody texted that he fell
here first they knew he hit his head he
was unconscious he was having seizures
they knew that he was in a bad way and
who hasn't been involved with high
school sports and concussions you know
you know this stuff I just think it's an
absurd statement I mean he wanted to be
part of this club you know if they fed
significant amounts of alcohol into him
your judgment immediately starts to to
go sideways and they continued to force
alcohol on him and all the other pledges
you said force alcohol you don't
consider your son a reckless person
absolutely
tim was a good guy he was not a drinker
he how do you know he wasn't a drink
I've talked to his friends in his
roommates I asked them you know I was
concerned yeah and they said no he was
not he was not a big drinker
I think that these guys just put so much
alcohol and told these young men and and
you know and then didn't watch them let
them be on their own well that brings up
an interesting point a lot of parents
hope that there's an adult in the room
as kids are partying and there's a man
named Tim bream the fraternities adult
adviser he was in the house the night of
the party he declined our request for a
comment do you think he should be
punished yeah well let's get this
straight there were all adults
Tim bream we believe is culpable but
they were all adults they knew what they
were doing they committed crimes and
after they committed those crimes and
put our son in grave danger they all
went to bed they were all adults they
knew what they were doing and then they
tried to cover it up the next day when
they knew that it was bad the other
thing that's so difficult is there's a
tape there's it's on tape that's what so
surveillance video surveillance video
and I can't stop thinking about that you
agreed to watch it only if you watch it
with the university president and the
trustees and the trustees right and you
wanted to do that why well I only wanted
to do that so they would do it so they
can see the severity of what happened
and we want them to watch it we
personally do not want to watch it but
if they make as we will but they need to
watch it so that they can implement
these changes and again they need to
enforce without enforcement none of this
is really gonna do anything Tom we've
heard Penn State's presidents say that
the university will quote push for
statewide legislation to toughen
penalties for hazing is the law the
problem well the people are the problem
but law is a great deterrent and we're
working with senator Corman the majority
leader in Pennsylvania we're also
working with representative million in
the Congress and we're looking to change
the law we believe that stiffer
penalties will mean will mean deterrence
and that's a key but if if there's a
parent who's sending their son or
daughter to college what's the message
that you have about safety
go in with your eyes open talk to your
kids this could happen to anybody if it
happened to Tim it could happen to
anybody and if it doesn't feel right if
something makes you uncomfortable if you
feel pressured don't do it you're not
invincible you're so important to
somebody somewhere
I also encourage all the parents that if
they hear something that they should
also speak up and say something we've
heard a lot of stories about severe
hazing at Penn State now from a lot of
people some have written letters to the
president others just let it go you need
to speak up there's you know yeah you
could be home you're still grieving this
is still very recent but you were
speaking up because you want people to
know this needs to change and change now
it can't happen to anybody else it's
it's just too awful yep we have a big
stake in this this is part of Tim's
legacy we have to we have to make a
difference thank you thank you all thank
you thank you thanks Jim and Evelyn and
Tommy thank you all for joining us this
morning